nous sommes à pripiat début février des
combattants ennemis se sont emparés de
positions clés dans la ville ukrainienne
mais leurs forces sont affaiblis c'est
le moment idéal pour les forces de
sécurité ukrainienne pour les
neutraliser
il reprendre le contrôle de la ville
reconnaissance aérienne tireur d'élite
ce sont les troupes du ministère de
l'intérieur qui lancent l'assaut
et secouriste formé par le canada
viennent en aide à la population civile
pendant que les combats se poursuivent
les bombes sont désamorcées des foyers
d'incendié sont éteints l'opération de
reconquête est un succès non sans que
les forces ukrainienne ne subissent des
blessures reçues
dans les faits tout ça c'est un exercice
qui vise à préparer la police nationale
au combat urbain les civils sont des
acteurs prix pyatt est une ville
désertée depuis l'accident nucléaire de
tchernobyl le décor parfait pour simuler
des affrontements en pleine ville en tad
invasion russe ces jeunes hommes seront
mieux préparés à une guerre imminente
inévitable diront plusieurs
si tous les yeux sont rivés sur
l'importante arsenal militaire de la
russie qui manoeuvre aux frontières de
l'ukraine il n'est pas la seule arme
dont il faut s'inquiéter
[Applaudissements]
l'attak des russes a déjà commencé elle
n'est pas le fait de lance missiles ou
de chars blindés mais plutôt menée dans
l'ombre depuis l'anonymat de serveurs
informatiques ou derrière le masque de
la désinformation
l'ukraine est sur la ligne de front de
ces cyber menaces depuis 2014 et pas que
d'un point de vue de cybernétique mais
aussi d'un point de vue de l'information
je parle de manipulation de la société
parce que souvent nous voyons que les
cyberattaques ne finisse pas cas
perturber nos systèmes et à semer la
panique pour influencer l'opinion
publique
c'est ce que l'on appelle la guerre
hybride et c'est une guerre à laquelle
l'ukraine et bien peu préparée dans le
tout nouveau centre de coordination de
la cyber sécurité on surveille
étroitement les attaques quotidiennes
contre l'ukraine cette carte interactive
montrant direct une partie de ces
attaques l'activité donne le vertige
des dizaines voire des centaines de
milliers d' attaques sont détectés tous
les jours mais toutes n'ont pas les
mêmes conséquences
elle se produit sur une base régulière
et elles deviennent de plus en plus
difficile et c'est vers elles sont
ciblées en fait depuis la fin octobre
ces cyber attaques sont devenues plus
grave et nous comprenons bien pourquoi
le 14 janvier dernier alors que les
tensions entre la russie et l'ukraine
étaient à leur zénith de nombreux sites
gouvernementaux ont été piratés kiev a
démenti un vol de données pendant l'
attaque et accusé la russie d'être
responsable
cet expert en cybersécurité fait partie
de la cyber alliance ukrainienne un
regroupement citoyen de pirates aux
intentions bienveillantes les chapeaux
blancs l'ukraine minimise la menace
croit-il bestiaux notre vrai du faux
tex ils ne sont toujours pas préparés
pour faire face aux attaques russes
parce qu en un seul jour les russes ont
réussi à fermer la moitié des sites
publics de notre gouvernement et à
détruire des données de plusieurs
ministères
aujourd'hui encore c'était au tour du
ministère de la défense et de banque
privée de faire les frais d' attaques
qui ont surchargé leur système
paralysant leur site internet
rochon quatre pattes se font rares une
sauf fsb nos visas virus au sein des
unités de piratage du fsv et des
renseignements russes sont très à l'aise
dans les systèmes craignait parce que
personne
personne ne peut les arrêter dans les
sous sols de cette université de kiev on
surveille aussi les attaques des russes
les moyens techniques qui sont plus
conventionnel mais chaque semaine c'est
ici que la plateforme stop fake expose
la désinformation véhiculée par les
médias russes et dangerous c'est
dangereux c'est dommageable
ousmane des niches en cours s'adresse à
la population russophone de l'ukraine à
chaque épisode il leur présente un
condensé de fausses informations
rapportées par les chaînes officielles
de la russie
c'est un acte de guerre c'est très
différent comme type de guerre mais ça
reste une guerre et c'est parfois plus
efficaces que des opérations au sol avec
des chars et d'autres armes
la propagande est une arme au même titre
que les miss et les les roquettes mais
c'est encore plus efficace
stop fixe se penchent uniquement sur ce
que l'on pourrait qualifier de
propagande officielle celle des grands
médias mais de plus en plus c'est par
l'entremise des réseaux sociaux que se
propage l'information fausse anxiogène y
clivante faux profils et trolls sont
autant de petits soldats au service de
cette guerre hybride la semaine dernière
les autorités ukrainiennes ont annoncé
avoir démantelé une usine de trolls qui
selon elle propage et la panique sur les
réseaux sociaux les quelques 18 milles
contre robotisée découvert dans cette
usine d'un appartement de l'ouest du
pays ont aussi servi à placer de
nombreux appels à la bombe dans les
écoles contribuant à climat de peur tous
ces comptes étaient supervisés par des
russes selon les services de sécurité
ukrainiens trois hommes ont été arrêtés
une petite victoire mais le combat reste
entier on est tous bénévoles agresseurs
nous devons pouvoir riposter contre
l'agresseur c'est pour ça que maintenant
une crème nous créions une cyber force
militaire qui pourra défendre notre pays
sur les lignes de front de la
déstabilisation il n'y a pas de trancher
pas de cibles stratégiques dans la ligne
de mire mais le fameux brouillard de la
guerre il est d'autant plus épais